first we have this story it's it's
hilarious Rudy Gobert made a mockery of
coronavirus touching all the microphones
putting his hands all over the place
dude yeah like rubbing his hands all
over the table have the video it's like
what yeah put the video food do I have a
better version of it I guess this is all
I have let me see if I can make this
bigger this dude I swear
look he's touching all the mics wiping
the table and then he laughs and walks
off he's like ha ha then runs off
alright alright hold on I'll get in
store in a second I'll get in story
we'll do we'll do a little intro hey
welcome to the show if you guys want to
get in the super chat we'll read your
comments we're chillin man it's gonna be
a relaxing day because we're at were in
South Jersey we're in the Philly burbs
they just announced that they're doing
one of these soft I don't wanna call a
quarantine social distancing efforts
they're banning all events in Jersey 250
people are more so we're sitting here
and I mean it's cool we got music we got
Magic cards and games and stuff we're
chillin but when you know we we were
sitting here staring at the screen with
like our jaws half open drooling because
literally okay not literally but
figuratively almost every single story
is just something about the coronavirus
it's like someone said X about
coronavirus like I don't care dude
but this one this this story is
legitimately funny this famous person
now has coronavirus yeah right alright
so let's let's let's first get into what
this story is if you if you checked out
my segments earlier on this you might
know a bit but now that dude's
apologizing and this is messed up dude
so this guy Rudy Gobert he's an NBA
player I know very little about the NBA
you don't watch basketball like that
they suspended the season viral video
shows NBA player Rudy Gobert touching
reporters Mike's phones before testing
positive for coronavirus good good good
show good sir yeah Bravo good sir yeah
it gets better
he infected some other dude apparently
so I wasn't sure you infected more than
just one other dude so so he see the
video it's like so here is really
touching all the mics following one
day's shoot around that some people are
concerned apparently do I have the other
story in the sky yeah Donovan Mitchell
confirms positive test after Jaz
teammate Rudy Gobert also reportedly
infected so the
I was reading the story earlier and
apparently he was going into the locker
rooms
uh-huh and like doing the same thing
touching everybody and laughing and like
rubbing up on everything you kidding me
I swear it was it said they said they
were he said he was quote being a
cavalier in the locker rooms touching
everyone's stuff Wow ah
dude like you got to be you know what
man there are so many people that are
selling with notably Buell it's like
okay man I look I get it there there
have been worse diseases there are worse
diseases but it's a bad disease it's
it's it's messing with people yeah and
if you think you're gonna go up in the
locker room and giggle like a little
girl and like you know okay well I
pageant a little girl cuz I was gonna go
mad but you want to giggle like a little
kid there's art rubbing stuff it gotta
be PC on the show and start rubbing
stuff all over the place laughing about
it and then he does it in the press
event oh man and then you get someone
else infected I wouldn't be surprised if
someone yeah I'm a stunt man what do you
think what do you think as teammates
we're gonna do when they they're all
getting sick now it's coronavirus dude
they're probably pissed but like it I
mean a team like that they got to be a
family so like it's like it's like your
brother doing it to you though so you
can't it I mean I know that's what I
worry right now I think there's there's
some camaraderie there like they
probably are more than just coworkers
but it's like he's definitely like I
don't know dude black like like hold on
hold on I'm something I don't know like
if they probably he's probably not going
to be invited to the next like
get-together if when this story broke if
you were like I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
hang out at the local gym and you know
high-five a bunch of dudes get sweaty
and then you came back and I'm like a
men's coronaviruses here so he started
giggling and rubbing all over her stuff
and touching everything and laughing
while you did it yeah and then I got
sick bro I would not be happy no I know
gasps no I'm not saying anything be
happy I'm saying they're probably
blacklisted him from future events well
I don't know what's separating a little
bit so he's apologizing oh that's nice
and so you know what I'll say this like
alright an idiot I wanted to give the
the general context of you know what had
happened for those that didn't know but
he's apologizing I'm gonna accept his
apology it's all we can do yeah yeah
they say utah jazz center rudy gobert
found to have coronavirus apologizes for
possibly endangering people well no no
no he did endanger people literally
endangered people and then
the people whose mics they were you go
up and get the mic and it's like man he
touched this one now the reporter this
mic was fine that's the mic that had the
chrono he was touching people's tape
recorders like in their Hawaiian do I
that I don't know man I would I don't
know what I would do I'd be so I'd be so
pissed if you dude if you had if you had
a cold and you came down here and you
were coughing and stuff I'd be like bro
bro I got to work I work every day man
he'll get me sick yeah these people are
playing NBA man they're gonna lose a lot
of money I'd imagine right welcome
India's on hold isn't it yeah
so whatever I don't know if they're
gonna lose money or how it's gonna work
out buddy but he did apologize let's
read the story CNN says to Utah Jazz
players who tested positive for the
novel coronavirus have updated fans on
social media as to how they were doing
Rudy Gobert an all-star Center from
France wrote I want to thank everyone
for the outpouring of concern and
support over the last 24 hours I have
gone through so many emotions since
learning of my diagnosis mostly fear
anxiety and embarrassment period good
yeah he also appeared to apologize for
an incident with the media that he said
came before he knew he was infected go
Bert's positive test factored into NBA
suspending its schedule following the
news the second player Donovan Mitchell
tested posted on Instagram that he had a
positive test I am going to keep
following the advice of our medical
staff and hope that we can all come
together be there for each other and her
neighbors who need our help the guard
wrote but they even are they been
showing is actual here we go okay well
not specifically referring to the
incident Gobert wrote on social media
that he needed to apologize to people he
might have endangered or no no he did in
danger yeah whether he actually hurt
them is the question right at the time I
had no idea I was even infected not an
excuse I was careless and make no excuse
hey there you go
I hope my story serves as a warning and
causes everyone take this seriously I
will do whatever I can to support using
my experience as a way to educate others
and prevent the spread of this virus he
wrote No all right that's it good good
saying yeah yeah he says I offer no I
make no excuse all right I'm embarrassed
I made no excuses that time I'd know I
had no idea was in fact it's I don't
care bro yeah why but I guess you know
he follows up with appropriate David
yeah dr. Stephen read director of the
u.s. Center for Disease Control and
Prevention's office of public health and
preparedness and
spots that's a mouthful of a title yeah
said it's Senate a Senate committee
hearing last week depending on the type
the novel coronavirus can linger on
services from hours up to a day I heard
it was a didn't you say yeah we uh it
was reported up to nine days up to nine
days yeah probably in like a colder
environment maybe right look at this it
doesn't do good in heat
I guess the video does not show other
media members wipe down the equipment
after Gobert touched them oh dude I
swear me all of these people that are on
Twitter laughing about how smart they
are just like I love it dude what you if
you you can laugh it whatever you want
bro mm-hmm this is what you laugh at is
none of my business so if you're on
Twitter and you're laughing at the
people who are going and buying in
supplies and all that stuff I'll tell
you what we make fun of people buying
toilet paper but if this stuff does get
really really bad yeah they're gonna be
laughing at us when we run out of toilet
paper you know I mean yeah you know I
don't know why people are rushing for
the toilet paper though people like
comfort I guess no no well yeah it isn't
aren't you head-on though wouldn't you
rather have full bellies and a tall
glass of milk or something but yeah what
are you gonna wipe if you don't have any
food in you but but here's here's what I
was gonna say like this guy was laughing
at everybody yeah thinking it was so
much smarter okay now he's sick you got
other people probably got other people
sick I'm sure there's mad people out
there that think it's nothing no big
deal yep still gonna pass out right now
yeah I'm sure yeah cuz I well obviously
I get a ton of people who message me all
the time about this stuff and some
people are like wow my family didn't
believe it at first and now we're
experiencing it there was a photo I
saved earlier I think it's from DC lines
out the door in DC so you've got all
these stores across the country where
people are literally just like waiting
outside for hours to buy stuff and I'm
left wondering two things the first one
the obvious on why the toilet paper the
second one due to Amazon I don't get it
you know we did people are you ready to
it I did getting stuff from China even
the other side no Emma's on warehouse
dude so so when when when when I saw
that all the toilet paper was with strip
trolley stores you know I did order
online I went on Amazon and click the
toilet paper button I was like 200 paper
and then the next day that you told a
brother Dave
you can subscribe to toilet paper yeah
and really yeah dude I'm stoked that
yeah subscribe to the annoying thing
about Amazon is that they offer to
subscribe to be from them they want you
to subscribe and like some things make
literally no sense like I was buying
wood glue and it was like buy a
subscription to wood glue and I'm like
why am I gonna need a bottle of wood
glue every month yeah I need some now
I'm gonna use it for a project I don't
need it next month what if you're making
chairs business yeah that's that's the
other thing too about the coronavirus is
whether or not deliveries are gonna
continue yeah yeah because I was
thinking about that you made the UPS guy
show up today and I was like what's the
point of not going to the store if we're
gonna have this guy who's literally gone
to all of these different houses had
people sign his thing grab it with their
hands
yeah and then come here back your turn
yeah yeah I'm gonna be like he asked me
to sign it and I did it with my pinky
anyway inside and wash my hands right
away yeah when you when I don't want to
sign that when you sign the UPS handheld
thing you are signing the hands of every
person that handheld signing thing has
been with yeah that's cute if I use my
pinky and went and washed my hands
immediately I don't you know and and and
I think this story with the Gilbert guy
mm-hmm makes me definitely not want to
have a like an optimism bias because
I'll tell you what you know even in the
past several several weeks when I've
been talking about how crazy this is
yeah I didn't want to I didn't really
believe it was gonna get this bad yeah
yeah I was like it's gonna be fun we're
gonna go to the store and buy a bunch of
beans and we're gonna make like you know
oh yeah that's really cool being taco oh
they have them the mixed bean bags
oh yeah that's it's like it's crazy it
looks like a rainbow of beans and I was
thinking was gonna be selling we're
gonna make like bean soup dude don't
mess with bean soup no no but I mean I
love my bean soup
I didn't think I'll take you outside
right now I didn't believe in the soup
look even though I was saying like I'm
take it seriously part of me just didn't
really believe it yeah yeah it's like
even though I was like come on can it
really happen I'm gonna go buy it anyway
and now here we are we go to the store
with a local local Walmart no toilet
paper yeah no totally yeah so well it
was trump issued this statement
yesterday right yeah that's right
yesterday last night
so last episode last night oh sure yeah
yeah we did an hour-long show instead of
two hours like we normally do and we
immediately you know we turn on the TV
listen what Trump is saying and then he
said he was suspending the the travel
yeah and we just saw collective like
holy whoa that's crazy because we know
people who are in who are in Europe you
know I have friends who were in Europe
and I don't know that meant but that's a
serious serious effort yeah that's
that's huge so I think I think you were
like even go to the store that you
brought it up yeah yeah and we were like
all right we were in the car
yeah go get some more stuff just in case
but I mean it's it's two blocks away
yeah it is and then I posted that photo
on Instagram of you looking in the
toilet paper aisle
how many shelves were empty dude it was
no no I was even welder prizing though
that there was actually the replacement
stuff you know how like they have they
cart over the poets and set it down it's
like alright that aisle is empty but
here's the pallet of the restoral stuff
but I was shocked to see that because
that's what I was expecting there to be
a lack of is the restock you know I was
assuming once all the stuff goes down
since China makes pretty much everything
but it's like that's probably gonna be
the restock but when the next one is
gonna start us to being slippery the
restock the restock stuff is normal oh
did I go to that Walmart all the time uh
yeah those boxes are always there okay
and the shelves are not always empty
yeah they were like empty and that that
would to me it was like whoa yeah I did
not so look man that we have we have two
Walmart's in our area and sometimes
they'll be missing something like will
go for cream yeah they don't have the
good organic cream and I'm like the good
or gang but they still have no problem
they first world problem the bread was
all gone the bread was mostly last year
right the bread was there was bagels
yeah
they only had bagels left but the bread
that was there was on the verge of
expiring like they hadn't gotten a
restocking at all and the water was gone
and toilet was all gone milk was all
gone all gone and that and that for some
reason the mac and cheese was all gone
but there's still some yeah there was
like the Velveeta I don't know it's it's
it's it's it's weird I know the toilet
paper eyeless dad blew my mind I didn't
think I didn't think man yeah cuz there
was no big line outside of the store
there wasn't like
although it was pretty busy for it being
all the commenting it's so weird that
it's so busy tonight and like well you
guys were here you didn't see the
address the president just say is
shutting down y'all a little weird of
course that then he said that it's not
gonna affect trade at all which makes
sense because I was I heard a doctor say
yesterday somewhere that you know even
if the product comes from China it's on
a boat for a while then it's in store
for a while
and then you might get it or even in the
Amazon factory sitting there for a while
it's like the virus won't last so the
bigger issue was in China it's that you
know dude coughing and wheezing who's
the delivery guy
yeah or literally like the UPS guy he
comes here all the time
ya know wave a different a PS guy it's
just like the UPS truck yeah yeah but
like he goes every house
I know it's any any any hands off a
thing to every person and has them here
you go sign it and it's like what do you
really do you know I mean mm-hmm
but here we are man New Jersey governor
wasn't the governor I think you'd think
they'd wear like a mask of some sort
they're probably gonna have to but the
mat it doesn't matter that's the problem
with people thinking they can use a
muggle mask don't work now not even that
what the reason why the doctors are
wearing all that is because they're
wearing gloves and the the smock - yeah
yeah so it's annoying we just people
wearing masks I'm like you realize it's
on your mask right yeah what are you
doing take it off you guys your hand
take it off behind the ears get the
strap yell it wide snap and drop and and
the assumption then is boom it got no
wear on your clothes I got no wear on
your hands I got no wear on your face I
do it in the shower no no no listen for
my bleach all over myself no no there
was a there the record I'm not saying to
do that there was apparently somebody
telling people to drink bleach and then
CBS or yes some news thing did a thing
about it like Newt snorting cocaine and
drinking bleach does not fix coronavirus
dude it like how do they think this is
real how are they reporting on a meme I
have you seen the movie Contagion cuz we
talked about contagion before I don't
know
I have or not to be honest na I have no
idea Jude Law I think it's Jude Law
plays a character who's got like this
fake cure and he gets a vent at the end
of it he gets arrested for peddling a
fake you or something
okay it's not it doesn't work at all I
mean I have to see the movie again
okay he's like doing a web like web
livestreams and he's like watch and he
like gives himself a shot like I'm cured
and then he claims it cures him or
something and then the FTC or whatever
comes in he gets arrested and fine like
a bunch of money okay but dude it's it
sounds like an exciting movie they're
companies right now that have masks okay
and so they're telling people to go buy
masks yeah
I'll tell you what the people here's my
understanding the people who are saying
masks do nothing mmm-hmm our try are
like I don't know these people just love
espousing the tribal nonsense they're
not being honest with you
the reality is masks help yeah the
problem is the effectiveness of a mask
is reduced to nil when you're walking
around without gloves without a smock
without goggles yeah so there's people
that are going on the subway in there
wearing a mask it's like it's in your
eyes yeah yeah that's it or it's in your
hands
right your gloves off and then touch
your face scratch your eyeball
you'll bring it back to your house so
here's an app touch the handle have you
ever seen have you ever seen like people
how people got of a hazmat suit because
I did this when I went to Japan you had
to do it Oh foo Kashima yeah yeah yeah I
had to wear the full suit like we had
goggles we had masks we had things like
hoods to pull up yeah cuz they're right
up the right octave particles get all
over your body and then when you're
leaving you have to take it take it off
from the inside out and people in suits
help you do it very carefully so the
particles don't get on you and it stays
on the outside and they ball it up and
they put into a special thing so what
happens when you're only running the
mask
you're covered in it no and then you're
like all right I'm taking my mask off
snap and then BOOM and then you take a
breath in and you're exactly your
clothes coronavirus mm-hmm so I guess
we're gonna be sitting around playing
Magic the Gathering for the next couple
weeks
slam pool yeah playing pool I think I'm
reporting on you guessed it coronavirus
yeah so we've I don't mean to make fun
of it but maybe a long-haul dude what do
we talk about you know I I just briefly
glimpsed a super chat yeah but I have
this bag that
I used to bring with me to every
conflict when I would go to okay and it
is covered in and God knows what yeah
tear gas black powder red powder residue
I have no idea yeah but I remember I
went to a trump rally in 2016 and I got
flagged because the dog smelled it and
like freaked out it nuts oh and they
were like what is this and they picked
those empty yeah and I'm like it's my
bag and they're like why is the dog
freaking out and I was like oh I report
from conflict zones and the guy kind of
chuckled it was like aha right buddy he
handed it back to me yeah but that's
what that's that's a thing like I think
that's funny because I had I didn't I
didn't think was anything wrong with
that bag yeah I couldn't smell anything
yeah that dog was like woah woah yeah so
you guys gotta check this guy out but
but that there's something going on here
but people don't you know I'm really a
lot more conscious of right now cuz when
we went to the store and they gave us
that the Purell things yeah to like wipe
the cart down oh yeah I always use those
anyway dude I never I never I never did
I always but it's but it's not just that
people are gross when you start hearing
about how people are getting this and
it's going like far and wide it's
proving me to me that people are gross
yeah well no it means that the amount of
human spit you ingest from other people
is like a lot every day it's true no
don't say that yeah it's true though
like people are touching their face mmm
so there's a video of Ocasio Cortez
telling people like wash your hands
don't touch your face yeah and then
throw out the past press conference he's
touching your face all over so look I'm
not trying to drag her cuz you know I
just like she's getting the hair out of
her face and stuff like that yeah but
people touch their face even when they
know they shouldn't it's just like a
reaction it's true and then you're
wiping all that stuff that's spitting
and whatever gets all over your face and
then you're touching stuff and then you
walk up and you grab it and then you
touch your face and then you know you
got like there's spit and a piece falls
in your mouth and then you're like you
swallow and you don't even realize it
this is gross yeah man
makes me realize how gross everybody is
people are gross that's what I was
saying made me made me think that like
we're all one you know if there is
something to take from this everyone
seems to be washing their hands now I
saw those a meme and it was like it was
a signed
in a restaurant and said you should be
washing your hands anyway yes wash your
hands
reminds me of a Ecklie I think it was a
Simpsons when like Homer walks out of
the bathroom okay and he's like that's
sign about washing your hands is only
for employees right like yes but yeah I
don't know man I'm like how much how
much money is gonna be lost from all
this I'm wondering oh wow definitely
unbe a what are we supposed to watch
when we go to rent an HL we can't even
go to the sports bar anymore you go to a
sports bar there's a sports but on the
streets it mainly got great wings yeah I
guess I guess we haven't because we've
been doing the show and it's like oh
that's true working good we're already
ready to be absolutely quarantine yeah
we're ready this is convenient for us
actually because you know you're busy
all day
I can't think we're busy all day many
many of us are busy you're chilling it's
actually I worked all day today did well
you've been building stuff man I object
at the house I have it yeah see see the
stuff Adams been doing people can't
really see but like we've got we had a
show in some guests and there's nowhere
for anyone to sit because we're in like
a studio yeah we can't have people you
know sitting around right exactly so we
had to set up an area kind of like a
greenroom where people can hang out so
you've been doing that yeah that's true
but it's actually convenient no we
started doing this this show and before
this I would finish and then actually
have the rest of the day to do whatever
else no it's not now it's 6:00 a.m. with
like a little window in between the
segments so now I don't care I'm
basically isolated we got a skate
session today that's good yeah that's
great that's why we put the skates up in
back here I know I know some people have
been asking for kind of like a tour so
maybe I'll maybe I'll do that yeah we
sometime tomorrow clean and then after
we clean yeah okay well we got lots of
time here yeah you know I'm not so
worried yeah I think it's actually cool
if we didn't have the internet true it
would be miserable do you think that's
gonna be an issue one day like some the
power might be gone like nah that's like
true post-apocalyptic when the power
goes out has suddenly everyone's without
power the fridge is all die have you
heard about that closed system solar
capture they
that was invited we do we talked about
that before now it's it's a fluid that
when the Sun hits it it changes the
molecules and then they can relate they
can convert the molecules back releasing
the thermal energy well in a closed
system I don't know too much about it I
was reading an article well that's not
awesome but but that's like so one of
the things it can do is revolutionize
just I'll talk my head revolutionize
like heating for your home yeah because
you'll have these like pipes running
across your roof absorbing all the
sunlight and then the fluid you know
runs on a system into the house and
releases the thermal energy to warm the
house basically moving the solar energy
inside so anyway here's gonna happen
a trajector we were trajectory we are on
there we go there's there's gonna be
probably a higher probability of
pandemics because we spend so much time
hiding indoors and working indoors yes
for that people are gonna have week at
weaker immune systems mmm-hmm
but it's not gonna matter because
everything's gonna be virtual and we're
all right robots will deliver stuff for
you yep we don't need the UPS driver
anymore it's gonna be bezos's robo drone
drivers yep
drones gonna fly to your house and then
just like drop the box and leave yeah
they're working on the their new Amazon
electric van now yep it's gonna be
coming soon so we're that's great so
it'll be like wall-e you know we'll all
be massively overweight in shares just
like with our eyes glazed over and then
the drone will drop the pizza on the
porch and then you our drum will go and
pick it up and bring it to us no one
will get sick anymore now dude we're
gonna still be skating outside we can't
skate no I'm not talking about chair
like necessarily I mean like humans us
Oh human like in a hundred years it's
gonna have a wall you can't believe that
yeah because you know why because Elon
Musk is gonna invent that that brain
connection thing yeah the neuro-link
neural link and then people are gonna be
morbidly obese in their hover chairs
with like their eyes glazed over they're
gonna sink up and go into a virtual
world where they can skate and not break
I don't really work out and yeah but
then they know everything cuz it's the
mother don't know you just can't get
hurt so they try crazy things and they
fall in balance around all essentially
yep so the matrix is no coming soon dude
if you had the opportunity to plug your
brain in and go to like the Skyrim world
and run around shooting fireballs when
you do it
I can't say now of course you would I
can't say no and I would anyone do it
for all unit for all you know we're in
it yes and just you know checking on God
mode and you're like I will freeze you
and then I will blow you up and this is
fun now I always shoot an arrow in that
dragon and then just fly away no better
yet if you've ever played Skyrim with
like no clipping on you just walk like
normal but you could walk up never have
you but I did play morrowind where you
can get the ring of flight or something
or maybe just like you weigh nothing
weightlessness and you just you can walk
up just like that I well it's actually
the right game you didn't need mom to
start walking up yeah and you're like
I'm gonna go as high as I can and then
you turn off and you [ __ ] start falling
yeah I totally do it and we all be
sitting inside so here's the point of
making it is about the coronavirus is it
it is good we're here round we have
video games destiny to just had that
thing come out or whatever
yeah season other worthy season of the
worthy there you go see so you got a lot
of people who are inside I don't care
you know didn't did Shadowlands Warcraft
come out I haven't paying attention so
the World of Warcraft I don't on yeah a
tension I'm I don't know that's coming
out no no I don't think it came out yet
I'm at revision 2 released basically
division 1 is like the same bad guys
Division 1 back to New York like somehow
you go from DC back to New York because
I feel like a lot of people were like oh
it's not in New York anymore oh it's not
Division one yeah what is New York
improved at all and I think it's gotten
worse that's so weird yeah I don't
really know what I know I haven't even
played it did they expand while I
haven't played in a while so like did
they expect I actually turned division 2
on yesterday just to like you know
what's going on in this and I was just
like I don't remember anything I'm gonna
start a new character and then I turn my
playstation off Oh check it out I think
it's cool because play it up with with
everything going on right now
excuse me with coronavirus it's
interesting
those aren't familiar division is about
like the plague or something it's like
yeah it's no it's an engineered virus
that's caused by this guy Aaron keener
well the first one anyway yeah and the
second one doesn't really have a story
it's just like it continues it's messed
up over here to go yeah but the first
one is about this guy who creates a
plague
ground zeroes in the center of New York
and it's basically you're trying you're
dropped in the middle of it and like you
have to find a guy so with that one game
yeah it was awesome Division one was a
lot I thought Division two was good yeah
I don't know I don't know what happened
they fix a lot of stuff yeah I think I
think I really did actually I really I
don't like that stop playing I played it
up until we started doing the you know
like world levels up or whatever yeah up
here no and then I was like I actually
don't like that system I don't like it
either yeah I didn't like it yeah you're
right I think that's what threw me off
because then it was like now everybody
everything you everywhere you go is
really difficult and it's like and then
even places that you've you know
explored already get taken away and you
have to like go save them and it just
became a chore I don't want to I don't
want chores I want to play and enjoy a
game yeah so well it's like you lose
your progress yeah yeah exactly
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts everyday after the show we make
them available in the community section
of this YouTube channel so don't forget
to subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you